there have been a number of Republican
dominated legislatures that have passed
laws Banning so-called gender affirming
care for minors it's not making it
illegal to get sex change operations and
medical treatment for adults It's All
About Kids there I have been states such
as Florida where the courts have struck
these laws down
as a violation of so-called trans kids
civil rights but we deny all kinds of
what we might call rights to Children
routinely we don't let them work in
factories buy cigarettes buy alcohol get
married nobody objects that it's not
fair that kids can't buy cigarettes so I
think this is falsely framed as a civil
rights issue